my name is Lisa Lowe and I'm a professor
in American Studies and ethnicity race
and migration before I introduce today's
speaker I'd like to thank Stephen pity
Matthew tonico and Nicole Edwards at Eri
TM whose support and assistance have
made the organization of the series
possible our speaker Jody Mohammed is
associate professor of English and
African American stuff Akana studies at
Marquette University she's the author of
representing destroy rationalizing
violence in the new racial capitalism
published in 2011 and she's published
many articles and chapters in a wide
array of journals and additions and
represent and destroy she analyzes the
shifts in the governance of race through
racial liberalism of the 1940s to 60s
liberal multiculturalism of the 1980s to
nineties and you know liberal
multiculturalism from the 2000s to the
present but of course paradigmatically
the Obama era she considers how
successive regimes of official anti
racism employee racial inclusiveness and
incorporated anti-racist
terms of value in order to limit the
radical descent that by black indigenous
and immigrant groups and to manage and
administer race within the nation as
well as to facilitate the expansion of
capitalism globally since representation
industry by represent and destroy she
continues to be concerned with analyzing
the processes through which the
administration of race translates the
world into terms that are conducive to
capitalism and permits permits the in
the intensification of racialized
accumulation and dispossession both in
the US and globally in the introduction
to the recent volume of social texts
titled economies of dispossession
the introduction of predatory value
economies of dispossession and disturbed
relationality Malamud with co-authors
Jody furrowed eligibility mentioned
already offers economies of
dispossession as a rich analytic that
permits us to understand multiple
historical and ongoing processes of
racial subjection colonial occupation
extraction and appropriation in a recent
piece using liberal rights to enforce
racial capitalism Mohammed with
co-author John and Eddie discuss how
neoliberal racial capitalism reproduces
liberal rights and operates through
administration they specify how rights
racialized
and differentiate the valued and devalue
not only through the withholding of
rights but through the granting of them
as well violent exclusion from national
belonging has characterized the
historical emergence of the United
States from its beginnings it justified
the destruction and dispossession of
indigenous peoples the enslavement of
Africans and Jim Crow segregation the
stolen labors of indentured people's and
immigrant workers and the losses of life
as the u.s. waged wars in Latin America
east northeast and Southeast Asia
Central Asia and the Middle East
yet violence accompanies not only
exclusion from the nation but inclusion
into it as well as emancipated slave
indebted for remember
rehabilitated inmates don't know the
violence of inclusion an operation that
proposes to convert subjugated others
into normative multicultural citizens is
also a process of racial governance
which interests during Obama more
regulation and administration of
individual rights and personal
responsibility provides a tighter weed
for elevating the privileged from the
stigmatized tracking the property than
the impoverished sorting the productive
from the disposable her current looks in
progress dispossession by administration
from which she will speak today
elaborates the problem of administrative
power and investigates its diffuse and
deadly capacities to give impunity to
racial capitalist violence through
seemingly neutral operations of
democratic procedural and technical
governance please join me in welcoming
professor Jody Muhammad whose lecture
today is titled operationalizing racial
capitalism administrative power and
ordinary violence thank you so much for
that just generous and comprehensive and
canny introduction which reminds me of
the dead of all the thinking I owe to
Professor those amazing canon of work
how are you guys doing this afternoon
it's great to see you all I am really
happy and honored here to be here with
you it's been great these last two days
or so great and great I guess right
these last few days are so being part of
the communities of thinking I'm really
grateful for all the graduate students
who come and spoken with me I'm grateful
for everyone who's hosted me Nicole
thank you for all the work that you did
to bring me here it's been wonderful and
I kind of want to cite and think a
little bit more about our collectives of
thinking together by just calling out by
name some of the people here at Yale
whose work and selves I've learned so
much from more than I can actually say
including professor Lowe Rod Fergusson
Matthew Jacobson Daniel ho sang hazel
Kirby daphne Brooks and Ned Black Hawk
and though he's not officially at Yale
you've already heard his name several
times today chandan ready my generous
and brilliant 20-plus
as collaborator is right here and I'm
hoping that he will take over a QA so
maybe you'll hear a bit more from him
later I also give gratitude and respect
to this land this long water land and
the people to whom it is kin especially
the EON Scot Tom Bakura quinnipiac I
thank my Mohican friends in Indian
country Wisconsin for helping me to see
this land as the homeland of their
relatives relations with whom were
formed in order to kind of safeguard
survival before mutual removal to what
is now Wisconsin can you guys hear me
okay I'm kind of trying to project but
I'm on sabbatical so I've been out of
the classroom a little bit but I just
want to finally thank each and every one
of you coming out despite the rain
despite the fact that it's Halloween
with the ordinary overwork and
emergencies to really hear and think
with me about some of my sabbatical
freedom dreams you guys are getting
things like right off the top of my
fever dreams freedom dreams I don't know
what they are but you're getting stuff
right off the top of my head so I'll be
really excited to get feedback from you
and I hope I can give you something you
can use right now because I do think
it's important right now to think about
administrative power as an
operationalizing power for racial
capitalism I'll be explaining that and
how this tranzact ability enforcing
power which I'll be talking about is
actually irreducible and so-called
Democratic democratic capitalist states
and is insulated by design how at this
moment it is being used by the Trump
administration and the post citizens
united semi privatized Republican Party
to further D cap acetate the already
hollowed out neoliberal administrative
state and to weaponize it for a
formation that critical sociologists are
calling a term I like and don't like
we'll talk about it more what critical
sociologists are calling authoritarian
neoliberalism which in the u.s. under
Trump I'll talk about as governance by
deal so first to riff more generally I
want to think about an administrative
power that is about enforcing forms of
appearance for transact ability
along within and constituting circuits
of capital accumulation
I think of administrative power as a Hal
of capitalism a power of encasement
partition abstraction and modularity
that seeks to format all constituents of
social process from human beings to
value making to nature for what Marx
called the capital relation right which
is not one relation but shifting and
variegated and multiple capitalist
relations set it sedimented for the
moment or momentarily out of a base a
moving base of competition between
capitalist blocks and what resists them
and what evades them administrative
power whitewashes the violence produced
by and for capitalist relations so that
the brutality of racial and colonial
capitalism's appears normal
necessary if regretable sometimes even
appears as just democrasy or democratic
process in action and to just thread a
few quick examples I'm gonna be riffing
here off of the Reverend dr. William
Barbour ii who's the head of one of the
co-chairs of the Poor People's Campaign
he was head of the unde double ACP in
North Carolina for a while he's a great
thinker of policy violence so riffing
with him
the decision of state legislators not to
expand Medicare isn't let die violence
it's just health policy immigration
officers raiding homes and snatching
children from bus stops isn't violence
it's just the normal defense of US
democracy mass criminalization
underemployment and debt economies in
black and brown neighborhoods aren't
Cena's administrated precarity by design
by the state but just public policy
issues right police killing itself is
immune to punishment if the state judges
that proper procedures were followed so
here's the crux of administrative power
thought about more theoretically that I
will unpack through the crux of the talk
and that is that administrative power
plays on the Deborah doubleness that
liberalism is always as we learned so
powerfully in professor Liu's work at
once classic liberalism so economic and
social and political philosophy and a
theory and practice of racial and
colonial management
that works by constituting and sorting
legitimacy and legitimacy to groups of
human beings who are different
differently situated in hegemonic state
capital relations so that for example
whiteness endures as a marker identity
for being able to exercise the capacity
to possess and stands in counterpoint to
blackness and ingenuity as social
markers for dispossessed ability
administrative power is a process power
and in the doing power frankly even more
and it gets done power it can be a make
do power to its hallmark is a kind of
recursive 'ti where a constituted or
instituted domination or hegemony
interprets and legitimates its own
violent constituting conditions as
democratic right fair and inevitable
however killing or criminal they were
and are and then applies these made
right conditions to predisposed the
future a recursive 'ti connected to the
force of the realization of materialized
circulations of capital accumulation
easier said connected to making facts on
the ground the power of what it is to
make facts on the ground in other words
it's a another way to think about it is
as a combined kind of state police
policy and capital power that appears to
be none of the above because the doing
that it does is precisely unthinkable
within liberal thought liberal thought
relies on distinctions between civil
society state policing and the free
market and on the idea that law direct
state action rather than state
capitalist force determining outcomes
first based on structuring conditions of
domination then assembling legal
justification and jurisdiction for
further reproduction ex post facto
something i'll talk about in a minute as
the law i need to say like - law -
administration - force continuum to
think administrative power we must break
with the fetish today of both liberal
and white right right-wing political
discourse for the separation of powers
right you guys hear about separation of
powers every time you look at a
newspaper or listen to a podcast right
because administrative power you
can't see it if you think separation of
powers of sweat is going on or what
should be going on right it exercises a
power that is at once legislative
adjudicated and executive which tries
and often happily fails to arrange
things so that day to day without it
being politicized the empirical
accumulative ends of reigning dominant
capitalist classes are met by hook or by
crook historically miss recognizing this
has been important for building
consensus for so-called democratic
capitalism in the US and making it look
democratic so this use of something that
looks like democratic procedural ISM or
mere administration or technical
efficiency to encase and insulate core
racial capital circulations from
democracy as people power is an enduring
feature of u.s. society from the
beginning right but it has a particular
gene E ology through the development of
the administrative state which was
inaugurated in the Progressive Era and
in the New Deal administration were new
capacities for the state to contest
capitalist exploitation for white
citizens right came side by side with
the building in of sort of administrated
social Darwinism it was contested in
revision through the long civil rights
period as the carceral civil rights
state to quote Naomi Murakawa repressive
Lee incorporated elements of social
movement struggles as it built in new
administrative punitive capacities and
then the Reagan era Institute's the
neoliberal state the Halloween out of
administrative capacities to safeguard
and redistribute while growing the
state's administrative capacity to
facilitate corporate capital
maximization but my focus today will be
on I think the next stage right so this
is a theory tell me what you think the
form administrative paper is power is
taking right now within the US racial
sector capitalist anti state state in
this period that social scientists are
increasingly calling authoritarian
neoliberalism so Ian brough used that
term in a 2014 article to describe the
emergence of a new liberalism quote
rooted in the reconfiguring of the state
into a less democratic
entity through constitutional and legal
challenges that seek to insulate it from
political conflict and that was in 2014
in his 2017 edited collection states of
discipline samal Barack tens L similarly
argued that even though the use of the
state to shield capital accumulation is
not new and it's not like neoliberalism
in general has been an exclusively
consensual process nonetheless there's
been a change in the everyday ordinary
ordinariness right of the ordinary
practices of capitalist states enough of
a qualitative shift in their normal
operations that we can talk about
authoritarian neoliberalism Zsasz one
operating through a pre-emptive
discipline which simultaneously
insulates neoliberal policies through a
set of administrative legal and coercive
mechanisms and limits popular resistance
against neoliberalism and to are marked
by significant escalation in the state's
propensity to employ coercion and legal
slash extra legal intimidation so
interestingly both critical sociologists
who want to warn us about it and those
right-wing academic and legal scholars
who want to keep building it up date
this authoritarian neoliberalism to the
same time which is basically to the 2008
global financial crisis and the
mobilisation of state power to save and
thereby further the continued dominance
of finance driven accumulation indeed
under Trump the checks and balances that
Obama kind of tried to put in have been
removed like the fiduciary rule was
rolled back the consumer finance
Protection Bureau has been all but
undone and then it's also been souped up
right at so we've got a tax code that
privileges financialized forms of
capitalism and just recently I think a
couple weeks ago he decided to make the
very extraordinary move of doing exactly
what was done in the time of the
financial crisis but just doing it
basically to like keep the stock market
up which is selling enormous amounts
having the Federal Reserve buy enormous
amounts of Treasury debt right scholars
distinguish between a rollback period of
neoliberalism where state focuses
on deregulation privatization and kind
of getting out of the way of corporate
finance and tech economies and this roll
out use the state period where hollowed
out state capacity is now weaponized to
benefit increasingly interlocking and
administrated logistical financial and
extractive global capitalism's so
clearly from the point of view of
critical race and ethnic studies
scholars indigenous critical theory a
career of color critique and all these
other social movement connected
interdiscipline it's interesting that
the sociologists don't mention words or
concepts like colonialism or imperialism
or white nationalism and indeed they
they tend to defend a once existing
better democracy so we see that they
kind of missed the side of liberalism
that's racial in colonial management and
sexual management as well right but most
importantly they miss what these
analytics can tell us about the weakness
of administrative heavy exercises of
power because the administration at the
end even though it's also like a make do
get it done power it's like get it done
as if it's still an as if power right
it's about controlling forms of
appearance of administration so a
transaction can happen it can be killing
and violent but there's always more
going on right there's always alternate
modes of collectivity other social
worlds continue and collectivities of
solidarities themselves that are
building everywhere and we'll talk about
some of those at the end
those themselves jam up accumulations
circuits and interoperability x' for my
purpose it's important that
authoritarian neoliberalism and tells a
shift as Chandan Reddy puts it from law
rule by lawmaking to rule by rulemaking
and even though they're not completely
different pages stuck together by the
humidity sorry so so okay on the one
hand it's true that nearly neoliberalism
has always been about administrated
orders as Quinn Slobodan tells us
neoliberalism is not about freedom and
free things happen in the market
regulating itself it's a practice of
global ordering regulatory systems and
institutions that seek to protectively
in case the world economy from
democratic pressure
but as Saskia Sassen Deborah Cowan and
others note we are witnessing
unprecedented successful administrative
post national encasements of flows of
capital through global institutions
rulemaking standardization and punitive
enforcement from the securitisation of
supply lines to World Trade Organization
law to globally Network financial
exchanges and there can be many many
many other examples right in fact
they're there they're marked by
opportunistic assemblages of business
investment and governance which organize
accumulation by articulating rules as
lowly as municipal zoning rules and as
lofty as sort of big global or regional
economic alliances like the European
Union or the Gulf Cooperation Council so
tonight I'll focus on how the Trump
administration uses administrative power
to weaponize the neoliberal eyes
administrative State for governance by
deal using administrative power as a
policing power increasingly turned on
the administrative state itself to put
it under executive control and make it
pliable to deal-making I will also
discuss policing itself as a
fundamentally administrative power the
power to fabricate operationalize and
regulate social order and abolish
disorder to the point of killing and
think about new modes of policing
emerging in line with authoritarian
neoliberal governance so if broken
windows policing has been our go-to term
for policing that accompanies that roll
back the state phase of neoliberalism we
might want to think of another term for
the policing that is happening during
this rollout phase of authoritarian
neoliberalism with state coercive
capacity expanding in the name of
interoperability and threat management
beyond conventional public private
police military and domestic
transnational distinctions and I'm kind
of in the larger work playing with two
terms one is interoperability policing
and the other is adapting from Shannon
Speed neoliberal multi criminalization
so any feedback on that very grateful
for it so briefly though to think a
little bit more about the
distinctiveness of liberal
administrative power in racial klonoa
capital's modernity i want to turn to a
passage from the beginning of marx
capital 1 section 8 so-called primitive
or original accumulation has anybody
heard of it all right it's like
everybody's talking about this right now
and Here I am I'm talking about it too
and I'm even gonna say cuz people are
like what we don't like primitive
accumulation we like original better and
I'm like well I don't like other than
one I don't like primitive or original I
like originally but actually what I want
to do is break down the germ in a little
bit so in German the phrase is bullsh
bring Nick Akuma lotzie all right and so
or shmulik or means like source it means
like the original point sprung lick
means like to spring from or to jump
from right so I like to think of it as
this part of capital is asking us to
analyze the recurring sort of jumping
off points or jumping off sources for
circuits of capital accumulation right
capital moving around which is never a
one-time thing and never the inevitable
outcome of past arrangements but it has
to keep jumping off again and again as
capital circulates along with its
constitutive and constituted violence at
all times and also at these world
historic levering changes in world
historic capitalist configurations so
Marx writes this section the very first
section of that this is the so called
primitive accumulation chapter at the
very beginning of section 8 and he
writes it as a kind of historical
materialist prehistory of the transition
from feudalism to industrial capitalism
in England right that whole sort of part
it's like he's suddenly become a
historian right but it actually all
begins with Marx making fun of the
prehistory endeavor and that's the
passage I want to focus on on how he
makes fun of how liberal political
economists use the same fairytale of
origins again and again to justify
property wealth and poverty and I'm
going to read that passage a little
little a little idiosyncrasy of
syncretic Lee that's a hard word to say
as Marx actually continuing to do what
he has done throughout capital so not
turning historian but continuing to
unmask house of capitalism right so at
this at this point in the text in
capital 1 he's unmasked the commodity
for him he's unmasked wage labor he's
unmasked the Working Day and I think now
he is unmasking
how of how capital accumulation
maintains the appearance of being
systemic continuous internally coherent
cumulative through time and
fundamentally economic despite its
constant reliance on social and
political violence the precarity it
produces for most which makes it
inherently insecure right and the crisis
tendencies of circulatory accumulation
itself
I read the functionally operable non
explanation of what Marx presents to us
as a fairy tale of the just origins of
wealth told whenever the question of
property is at stake as illuminating
administrative power as both substantial
and empty and open secret undisclosed at
gunpoint alright so I'll try to read
this in a bit of a fairy tale way if
it's super annoying that I'm reading it
in the fairy tale way I apologize in
advance but it started written that way
so here here's the passage primitive
accumulation plays approximately the
same role in political economy as
original sin doesn't theology Adam
didn't Apple and thereupon sin fell on
the human race it's origin is supposed
to be explained when it is told as an
anecdote about the past long long ago
there were two sorts of people one the
diligent intelligent and above all
frugal elite the other lazy Rascals
spending their substance and more and
riotous living thus it came to pass that
the former sort accumulated wealth and
the latter sort finally had nothing to
sell but their own skins and from this
original sin dates the poverty of the
great majority who despite all their
labor have up to now nothing to sell but
themselves and the wealth of the few
that increases constantly although they
have long since ceased to work such
insipid childishness is every day
preached to us in defense of property as
soon as the question of property is at
stake it becomes a sacred duty to
proclaim the standpoint of the nursery
tale as the one thing fit for all age
groups in all stages of development in
actual history as is well known conquest
enslavement robber
robbery murder in short force play the
greatest role right and hard work were
forever the sole means of enrichment
naturally with the exception each time
of this year so I'm drawn to this
passage in the
first place because I see it as a trick
but I think of it as a trace of the
trick of racialization in the text of
Marx right it's it's a fairy tale about
capitalism's original diversity the
frugal elite and the lazy Rascals the
producers and the parasites right to
quote Daniel ho sang and Joseph Lau and
Landis and it's easily transpose ax
below what racism does for capitalism
which is to legitimate the inequality
Kappas and requires to create fictions
of differential human worthiness and
unworthiness of legitimacy and
illegitimate and to use these to fix and
justify exploitative relations between
social groups so the fairy tale of race
is a technology for sorting human beings
is an administrative procedure for
racial capitalism but as we see from the
passage so is property so is virtue so
is right and all of these knowledge
power categories central to liberalism
act as administrative anchors in tandem
to whitewash capless making kappas
preserving violence I read that last
recursive part of the passage where it
is well known that conquest enslavement
robbery murder in short forests played
the greatest role in ruther in wealth
accumulation but right and hard work
forever appear unconvincingly as the
sole source of enrichment as telling us
something about the work liberal
administration does along a law -
administration - force continuum to
relentlessly convert violence into
transact ability for capitalism so
according to liberalism universal laws
are made consensually they are neutrally
administered and when necessary where
there is law breaking force is used to
restore law and maintain order yet this
passage tells us that something really
different is happening along that law
administration force continuum from this
perspective accumulation is
operationalized through force then made
to appear not merely legal but a neutral
managerial outcome recursively
administration does not apply but
handles law and predisposes future now
legitimate use of force so rather than
the non political link between law and
force administrative powers very
political work is to in an instant
adjudicate capitalism's foreground and
background violence in action
is making the capital relation interpret
or make law to accord with these actions
and then recode capitalist making
violence into capitalist preserving
policing to predispose further transact
ability and reproduction it's a
recursive feint of encasing legibility
operational violence and what gets
produces facts on the ground similar to
what Aileen Martin Robinson calls the
white possessive and I love her
definition of the white possessive it's
quote the process through which the
materiality of significations such as
material building that really exists or
material deed that I really hold in my
hand are perceived we might say
misperceived
as evidence of ownership by those who
have taken possession already missing
from Marx's analysis of the story of the
worthy frugal elite and the disposable
masses and the story of the conquest and
theft turned into property and right
maybe because it goes without saying is
the police to quote the title of an
important book by Mark Nia close it is
the function of the police to fabricate
social order against the myth of a
spontaneously generated civil society
and the idea of the free market nucleus
tracts security as the concept through
which the state imposes order on civil
society and organizes market conditions
through police power right so policing
not as an institution but an activity
not as an entity but a function police
power as administrative power writ large
because it involves nothing less than
quote securing the system of social
domination including racialized gendered
and colonial class relations to quote
the eighteenth-century
police political theorist Patrick Cole
kahan quote police is the constant and
never failing attendant of the
accumulation of wealth the acceleration
of wealth can only be achieved by
establishing the correct system of
police so to understand this better for
contemporary neoliberal racial
capitalism I want to quit turn quickly
to ruthless and Gilmore you guys know
Ruthie's work recent Gilmore's work like
golden gulags rights and golden gulag
Gilmer examines the growth of a
racialized prison economy in California
in the 1980s and 90s and how it
just sort of a fix for surpluses of
capital and land and labour and state
capacity and in other work
what Gilmore teaches us basically is
that if capitalism requires inequality
and racism enshrines an equality
capitalism requires policing
administrates guarantees produces
fabricates racial capitalists
asymmetries of austerity to the point of
killing in an interview in The Guardian
right after the Baltimore uprising in
response to the police murder of Freddie
gray in 2015 Gilmore said something that
I found really helpful and I thought
about for a long time I thought about it
for a long time in the shower walking
down the street okay so and this is what
I thought it seemed so simple but it got
I got really deep ok I think she gets
deep really fast so this is what she
said I think many people respond to
these high-profile police killings by
thinking they can kill us because they
can lock us up but I think it goes the
other way they can lock us up because
they know they can kill us they can kill
with impunity in other words we have to
think deeper than processes of
criminalization they can kill us because
they can lock us up right it's true of
course masks romanization of people of
color leads to police killing but
Gilmore wants us to think deeper they
can lock us up because they know they
can kill us because they can kill with
impunity that is at the root of things
that's not only police power bound up
with racialized criminalization its
police power bound up with the
fabrication of racial set their
capitalist orders policing is the power
to administrate capitalism to the point
of killing with impunity for Nia Cleo's
the crux of the police function in 19th
century England was to fabricate wage
labor by policing the poor and in
particular policing and thereby
fabricating a line between poverty and
the rabble between the merely poor whose
participation in wage labor marks them
as moral and legitimate and the indigent
whose economic inactivity or subsistence
outside of the industrial class system
marked them as immoral idle and unworthy
right poverty can't be abolished right
because that would abolish class Society
so instead the administrative project of
the police for neo cliffs is to quote to
prevent the poor from becoming
able to quote teach them the immorality
of crime police are not citizens in
uniform but Street administrators of the
state protecting property and ownership
who use their discretion a concept I'll
talk about more in a minute to decide
who is merely poor and who is criminally
indigenous can you guys still hear me
back there have I gotten like slow or
losing anything just keep going okay
look again thanks for the feedback if we
think about this task of policing is
fabricating social order by policing the
line between the legitimate and the
illegitimate the poor and the rabble for
today's rising authoritarian
neoliberalism as structured by ongoing
southern colonial dispossession racial
arbitrage and hetero patriarchal
routines we see new complexities not
only policing the poor of color but
policing the line between poverty and
disposability and policing lines of
legitimacy and illegitimate Asiya with
enormous flexibility and fastness that
is pre-emptive pervasive pervasive yet
able to micro-target
operating through fusions of police
military and private security leaning
more on commodification of pacification
across multiple scales and jurisdictions
and producing shifting yet modular
categories of multi criminalization
chundan ready gets at this in his
discussion of asset less individuality
as the right to be handled as how people
without assets once individuated and fed
into these administrative machines
become highly flexible so that in one
moment they can be coded as you know
wage labor in another instant they can
be the raw material for prison
warehousing and another instant worthy
of credit baiting and in another
indebted generators of fines and fees
shannon speed gives us another example
in her book states of violence
indigenous women migrants in the era of
neoliberal multi criminal ISM speed
argues that as states in the americas
become increasingly more authoritarian
neoliberal and corrupt and as the
economy offered to the poor and the
indigenous is increasingly one of
illegality central american indigenous
women migrants are interpreted
multiple-- as criminals and different
kinds of criminals right so Central
American states interpolate them as poor
peasants likely to commit criminal
offenses related to poverty and subject
them to colonial gender
violence Mexico then interpolates them
as potential drug traffickers and
non-citizens who can be blackmailed and
worse and in the u.s. they are recast
from asylum seekers to terrorists and
criminal aliens finally in terms of
discourses of neoliberal multi
criminalization I hate it but we have to
mention it right there's Trump's you
know constant delineating of who's a
legitimate who's an enemy of America
right it's Muslims it's refugees it's
african-americans it's the media it's
Democrats it's immigrants it's Nancy
Pelosi it's Mexican nationals it's
political activists right it's all of us
right it's all of us at some time so his
constant ruling on the alleged Asiya of
groups for opportunistic deal-making
with white nationalists and other
self-dealing so what strikes me in terms
of contemporary policing for
authoritarian neoliberalism is the
extension of racialized impunity for
police killing us raw administrative
police power in the killing of Eric
garner for selling loose individual
cigarettes we can see police killing
power used to punish the asset lists for
participating in a secondary economy in
fact the most recently published police
administration textbook justifies
Garner's killing by stating that sales
of lucy's in New York quote deprive the
state and city of a combined $6.95 per
pack in Milwaukee where I live the
police killing of dontre Hamilton for
sleeping on a bench in front of a
Starbucks can be seen as a defense of
real estate financial capital with
dontre's sleeping body like the bodies
of asylum seekers itself being seen as
an offense to a thorough chair and
neoliberal capless orders and then
there's the fused ice police
relationship that allows pursuit to the
point of killing that raychel buff calls
the deportation terror and we can tell
that impunity is irreducible to police
power as administrative power because
whenever impunity is called into
question we get a fairy tale right we
got a fairy tale like I thought she had
a gun a fairy tale like I field for my
life a fairy tale to quote US Attorney
Richard Donahue quote there is nothing
in the video to suggest that officer
Pantaleo intended or attempted to place
mr. Garner in a chokehold use of force
standards like objective reasonableness
and categories police used routinely and
patrolling such as obstruction and
reasonable suspicion are also
fairytail euphemisms for the exercise of
police power impunity and its twin
discretion are necessary for policing as
political administration and they take
on new weight as authoritarian
neoliberal orders and they're
opportunistic modes of accumulation
require flexibility pre-emptive
capabilities and deadly violence against
rapidly shifting targets discretion
gives police the operational power to
structure every single encounter on the
fly to look the other way or pursue to
warn or arrest to insert someone into
the criminal justice apparatus of human
sacrifice and impoverishment or not
liberal law and order discourse often
points to discernment as the weak point
in policing right that that policeman
acted in a biased way that they made bad
decisions they went after the wrong
person they didn't follow procedures but
discretion is in fact not a weakness in
policing but the source of its
operational strength if there was more
time I'd like to think with you more
about the relationship between police
discretion and what Nikhil Singh calls
the whiteness of police and what Daniel
Xhosa and Joseph flounders investigate
as producer patriot masks honest
identity formations basically we need to
think discretion outside of concepts of
liberal individualism and individual
calculation because when we do that
police violence is individualized and we
get the administrative trick of
punishing the few bad apples putting
them on administrative duty or making
bad departments undergo retraining which
circularly and reinforces the
administrative power of the police
rather discretion is a way of fixing the
structures of social domination durably
in the experiential and live
dispositions of social subjects who in
the case of the police are often
socialized to act in accord with
background conditions structured by
structural masculinism white supremacy
settler colonialism nationalism and an
anti Arab and anti-immigrant racism this
means that the administration that the
police function does on the fly to
survey to inform repress arrange things
on the street draw that line between
poverty and disposability can be done
with discretion in an instant in accord
with all these background conditions
even as to the police it is enforcing
law against moral offenders importantly
the discretion impunity continuum
mirrors the law administration force
continuum in that police action winds up
determining what the law means with
judges continually deferring to police
understandings
and standard operating protocols in
determining the scope of Fourth
Amendment protections today police
impunity has taken on new dimensions
with new modes of policing for example
the fusion center and supply chain
security represent complex new
assemblages of police power including
local state and federal police military
federal intelligence corporations and
corporate security and global and local
private security and criminal justice
technologies and all kinds of social
police from emergency management
personnel to workfare administrators the
assemblage these assemblages achieve
impunity through their administrative
complexity itself and ambiguous
jurisdictional claims and non claims
loosely organized around protecting
critical infrastructure and enabled by
anti-terrorism laws fusion centers
create the conditions of
interoperability that enable neoliberal
multi criminalization yet as we have
found out and for example the criminal
persecution of Tiger Swan in the
continuing notable activism they're
subject only to be persecuted as
individuals right
impunity also takes on new dimensions
when increasing the administration is
the punishment policing is the
punishment right we can think here of
the trauma illness and killing inducing
administrative detention of asylum
seekers as well as the punishment of
everyday life for black and brown
migrants under surveillance threats and
other forms of administrative violence
like deportation we can also think about
the ongoing social control of the
colonial police scene of American
Indians and the anti-democratic
discipline exerted through policing on
economically exploited black communities
such as ISA colder Houseman documents in
misdemeanor land her study of how New
York City's lower court criminal justice
system has basically abandoned at
adjudicate model of criminal law like
figuring out who's innocent and guilty
for a managerial model which imposes
stigma surveillance and ability without
formal conviction or punishment all of
this means that fighting so this is a
happy moment here all of this means that
fighting police killings police impunity
and law enforcement discretion that is
the punishment whether you're doing
direct action or you are just living in
the thickness of kinship love everyday
ground relationality and the social more
than human context that administrative
power tries to deny is part of living in
revolutionary time do you
David wrote ogres language of shaping a
beautiful experiment two quotes idea
Hartmann or living in a good way to use
the colloquial from Indian country now
we get to more depressing stuff and then
some less depressing stuff again at the
end because we're turning to the Trump
administration okay and we might say
that the Trump administration uses its
rules and rulemaking like the police use
use of force rules which is to do what
needs to be done which is not
individually determined in order to
enact transact ability and to predispose
the reproduction of further transact
ability I will focus on how the Trump
and the Koch Mercer arch-conservative
networks he sub contracts to are using
administrative power right now to try to
break the administrative state and
Institute a post civil service model of
deal-making governance so on one level
the Trump administration is using Trump
is using executive administrative powers
to make the same old deal of winning
consent for capitalist rights by linking
them to white supremacist Christian male
prestige and favor right the steel
making is done through executive orders
and administrative actions that
frontally attack the well-being and
civil and human rights of legal and
unauthorized immigrants refugees Muslims
and Arabs LGBTQ persons American Indians
and the poor of color these attacks are
done by executive order I think of them
as fascism by federal register and are
so numerous that I could list them to
you for hours literally but you know
them right it's the Muslim ban since the
attacks on Dhaka it's the undermining of
LGBTQ rights in the last month it's the
proclamation to deny naturalization to
legal immigrants who could be considered
who you know who have used social
services by saying they violated the
public public charge thing or to not
allow legal immigrants in who unless
they can prove that they have health
insurance right it's this the gutting of
numbers of refugee admissions there's a
great group civil rights org has a day
to day list of these administrative
orders and guidances and executive
orders and it keeps a running tab so
check this out on a second level there
is the self-dealing the discretionary
use of the Office of the President for
personal gain including the business he
generates for his hotels and clubs all
the emoluments issues that have to do
with the five
business entities which Trump has
refused to divest or put in blind trust
and the more than 750 conflicts of
interest concerns that the Sunlight
Foundation has tracked there's also that
incredible amount of crony capitalists
deal-making for donors and other wealthy
elites in the administration's favor
again I could list these endlessly but
one example as reported in the May
twenty nineteen Public Citizen report is
that the National Association of
Manufacturers under Trump has achieved
more than 85 percent of their wish list
of deregulation and one the delay repeal
of more than a hundred and thirty
consumer worker and environmental
regulations the third level of
deal-making I'll discuss is accelerating
under Trump but has its roots in
right-wing conservative activism since
the 1970s to end the remnants of the
functioning New Deal or carceral civil
rights administrative state won by
bringing it in line with the right-wing
theory of the unitary executive the
theory that article 2 of the
Constitution gives the president power
over every aspect of the executive
branch and all federal agencies so
exactly like a king but it's supposed to
be like really really democratic because
he was elected okay so that's all you
need that one guy to be elected and he's
in charge of everything because he's the
one the people voted in number two by D
functioning administrative agencies
through personnel rules and shenanigans
and three by weaponizing the regulatory
machinery to force deals that leverage
the power of the states and not just get
the state out of the way but force deals
that leverage the power of the state and
public resources including people's
health well-being and freedoms for the
gain of private not necessarily domestic
hapless entities we can think about this
just to throw out something like the war
on California right the Trump
administration swore in California for
our purposes it is highly ironic that
right-wing conservative attacks against
the administrative state the deep state
the swamp the soul-killing domain of
career bureaucrats right it in fact
catches hold of something real about the
insulated operational power of
administration that insulates the state
from democratizing movements there are
accusations of overreach or
unconstitutional delegation in a warped
way acknowledge that federal
administrative agencies exercise a power
that is at once de facto legislative
judoka Tory and executive that agencies
the EPA the
education the USDA you name it issue
rules that are intended to have the
power of law that internal
administrative law judges rule on
complaints and conflicts and that fine
fees and other actions are enforced
against violators of the agency rules
yet in the name of restoring democracy
and individualism and the fairytales
again of constitutional ization and the
separation of powers the real aim is to
break the civil service state in other
words its right-wing attempts to kill
the administrate both criticize and
cease the operational powers of the
administrative state which liberals
generally do not acknowledge and the
battle is really raging right now in
administrative law I have learned a lot
from administrative legal scholars about
this and I especially want to point to
Gillian Metzger's 2017 Harvard Law
Review article called 1930s redo the
administrative state under siege
Metzger tracks the long history of
conservative resistance to
administrative government's that since
the New Deal state since the New Deal
stayed and it's constant reliance on a
fairy tale of the separation of powers
as what democracy means even as we see
right-wing activists continue to use
every branch of government the Judicial
Congress executive also the Academy to
disable redistributed and safeguarding
the administrative apparatus is and it's
really reaching ahead now at the Supreme
Court I don't know how many of you're
tracking this right where Alito has long
been an advocate of unitary executive
theory where Thomas has long argued
against modern-day delegations of
executive authority to agencies is
unconstitutional where Roberts recently
wrote in a ruling that quote the dangers
posed by the administrate cannot be
dismissed and where Gorsuch the most
extreme anti administrative state
justice wants to immediately end
delegation and make Congress impossibly
responsible for everything agencies do
from regulating drugs to making land-use
decisions as justice Elena Kagan puts it
conservative activists are now quote
working to quote overturn cases that
have long been central to the federal
government's ability to function
properly to protect consumers and keep
people safe and indeed the Trump
administration has already appointed 150
judges at the federal level and which
constitutes about 25 percent of the
federal judiciary right so a lot it's
going to continue Trump or not in
Congress activist lawmakers have put
forth a series of legislative proposals
that would paralyze federal agencies
putting the
under host of new procedural and
analytical requirements this includes
the separation of powers Restoration Act
which would end judicial deferment to
agencies interpretations of the rules
the reins act regulations from the
executive in need of scrutiny that would
require all new economically significant
regulations to be approved by both
chambers of Congress and the regulatory
Accountability Act that would replace
normal regulatory procedures with a
trial-like process called adversarial
rulemaking the point is none of these
things would work right none of they
just wouldn't work they just wouldn't
work its way of making sure agencies
don't work anymore
meanwhile the Trump administration has
used executive power to dramatically
denormalize and weaponize agencies for
deal-making
it has appointed department heads who
have either expressed hasta to hostile
hostility hostility that too should the
purpose of the agency or long term
corporate lobbyists like you guys know
this Rick Perry and energy Betsy G
Fawcett education Dave Barnard and
interior and the newly famous Mick
Mulvaney who was at one time headed the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
but what probably has been most
effective and if you have friends or
family members who work in the Federal
service probably already know about this
right but what has been most effective
at hurting agencies has been Trump's
work to demand dismantle them at the
level of personnel by not filling
positions especially those that call for
scientists or other professional
expertise finding ways to reclassify
jobs so they can be occupied by
political appointees rather than civil
servants cutting budgets and
particularly destructively relocating
agency after eight after agency out of
DC and fragmenting them often without
paying for relocation or having good
plans to keep them working and this is
indeed already happened to the Bureau of
Land Management and much of the USDA and
just this week Senate Republicans
proposed an act that would move 90
percent of cabinet level departments
including the Office of Management and
Budget and the General Services
Administration and this was the cynical
Mis right it would move them out of DC
fragment and split up families making it
possible for them to do the work in the
name of putting them in economically
distressed neighborhoods to bring
development and well into those
neighborhoods right especially
pernicious as the Trump administration's
attack on administrative law judges and
administrative adjudicators who have
been reclassified from employees to
inferior officers making it more easy
for them to be fired and controlled by
the president
and politically appointed superiors such
as administrative law judges who make
undesirable rulings can now just be
fired and actually the rulings can also
be overturned by department heads
according to the Southern Poverty Law
Center the goal is to quote transform
immigration judges into deportation
enforcers and I want to talk just a
little bit about Trump's use I'm getting
close to the end here of the OIRA the
Office of Information and regulatory
affairs as a good example of the
aggressive use of administrative power
for roll out authoritarian neoliberalism
that preemptively disciplines and
forcibly instrumental eise's
administrative apparatus or deal-making
and like if this is meant to be boring
right it's meant to sound bright and
make you not want to think about it but
there's a lot of power happening here so
the OIRA
is a sub-agency neutrally described as
the central authority for executive
review of regulations and approval of
government information and statistical
collection and practice but in truth
since it started in the Reagan era it's
been a way for the executive branch to
gate keep every other agency right and
the regulations they want to pass and a
way to connect private industry and
corporate lobbyists right to to the to
those agencies a back door it's chief
mechanism of control up until the Trump
administration was to subject all agency
rules to cost-benefit analysis which
means many regulatory battles could be
won just by monetizing everything and
showing how expensive regulations would
be to implement to push back a little
bit Clinton and Obama tried to calculate
something that they did calculate
something they called social benefit
right so for carbon emissions on health
impacts the Obama administration
estimated that that would cost $33 for
ton of carbon the Trump administration
knocked that down to $1 right for no
reason and with no science between it
and basically where the Trump
administration has just started doing is
no longer calculating benefits only
costs only costs right one of the first
things the Trump administration did in
terms of executive orders was to begin
turning the OIRA into a police in an
enforcement mechanism by passing this
genius executive order right reducing
regulation and controlling regulate
costs which is that for every two
for every one rule you want to pass
regulation epa or USDA or whoever you
are you have to repeal to and it has to
be like budget neutral right that it's
like a lot of sense in that right at two
four one two four one rule and then he
passed thirteen seven and seven one
reducing regulation and control and
regulate that was thirteen seventy seven
actually enforcing the regulatory reform
agenda which mandated that ever every
federal agency has to create a
regulatory reform officer and task force
whose everyday job it is is to identify
regulations that can be repealed a third
executive order promoting to energy
independence and economic growth boosted
conditions for oil gas and energy
industries calling on all executive
departments and agencies to review
energy regulations and rescind those
with burdensome economic impacts so so
far he's killed his ori a has killed 195
regulations and how many think they have
been passed zero i mean it kind of
should be zero right to to like somebody
muted something to happen there there
are two two of them passed but this week
a new order having to do with
regulations was passed that i think
shows where things aren't going right
this one was called executive order on
promoting rule of law or ad always mess
was in trouble when it's that executive
order promoting rule of law through
improved agency guidance documents so
guidance documents are how agencies
actually take the rules that they've
made right that are very like broad and
provide guidance for how the rules
actually mean how key you can implement
them in your business what the timelines
are right they're really like that how
to do it thing now this order says that
federal administrative agencies can no
longer use guidance documents if it
can't be but they can write anything a
guidance document that would be binding
which is just how federal agencies work
right and it advances us towards
substituting deal-making for the
administrative state by saying that
anyone who might be affected by a
regulation has to be told about it in
advance so that their input can be
solicited before it is written right so
make the deal from the beginning not
just block the law but like be involved
in writing the regulation so we so we
which should be clear right Trump's
chaos is a powerful means to an end
but breaking the administrative state
has been and will continue to be the
goal of right-wing conservative and
libertarian activists who dominate the
Republican Party and they are already
preparing for what comes next in a white
paper prepared for the coke funded
George Mason Center for the study of the
administrative state actually entitled
and I saw this after I already used all
this language I promise that it's a
little spooky that it's the same
language this this white paper was
called the deal-making state executive
power and the Trump administration it's
written by UC Berkeley professor of law
Stephen Davidoff Salomon and Wharton
School professor David Zarin and it
literally offered the Trump
administration a blueprint for how to
substitute deal-making for the
administrative state normalize it and
make it workable quoting from the white
paper quote the Trump administration has
promised to pursue policy through deals
with the private sector not as an
extraordinary response to extraordinary
events but as part and parcel of the
ordinary work of government here we the
authors explore the ways the Trump
administration can avoid ordinary
Administrative Procedure by using
private channels to meet policy goals
and orig to normalize this bid to
reorient the state around deal-making
they provide two examples of how it's
been done already it's already normal
and talk about like ordinary racial
capitals whence their first example that
they just throw in it's so stupid their
first example is the Louisiana Purchase
right that that was Thomas Jefferson's
best thing he ever did right it was the
best deal ever made a secret deal to
purchase 800 million square miles of
land from France right and then their
other example is the quote unquote
rescue of the financial system 2006 to
2008 right through bespoke agreements
with individual financial institutions
and they offer that example is proof
that like even though this might sound a
little scary to change everything you
make it about making deals hey that was
good for social welfare wasn't it right
that deal making that what happened so
we should just do that all the time
right we should figure out how to rule
by dealing non-crisis times such that as
they say
transactional governance can become a
way of life though they acknowledge the
deal-making governance might not be
might be seen as an erosion of
democratic norms they lay down the gun
that by saying well whether you like it
or not has to do with your feeling about
the ossified administrative state and
anyway they have workable problems you
know for a she's like transparency and
accountability their modus operandi
would be quote a legal arrangement
negotiated by sophisticated outside
lawyers acting in the government's
interest to meet the problems of the
transactional approach so v security
lawyers will take a right transparency
issues well we'll put it in the Office
of Management and Budget and from there
if you want to find out about any deal
making that's going on you could you
could do a Freedom of Information Act
and just see what's going on right and
then the other thing is that in order to
make sure that parties who are unhappy
with government deal-making have their
day in court we got to make sure that
people can sue if they don't like the
deals that were made so there a plan for
lowered governance led by a dealmaker in
chief is obviously a really stunning
example of insulating state capless
transact ability from even the already
insulated processes of the nation-state
requiring only a bevy of lawyers rather
than three million federal civil
servants
so clearly the current impeachment
inquiry arises out of conducting foreign
policy as deal-making and it is
heartening to see the administration's
malfeasance exposed by civil service
professionals and that has been the
story right the administrative stayed
trump has worked so hard to break might
be his undoing but as is clear from the
barely lawyers letter to Nancy Pelosi
stating his non-cooperation with an
illegitimate impeachment inquiry the
Trump administration's real power is his
political base held together by
whiteness Maskin ISM patriotism and
resentment people who see themselves as
the only legitimate US citizens and the
betrayal of Trump as the betrayal of
themselves and the nation and clearly a
return to the more normal neoliberal or
even carceral civil rights
administrative state the management of
so-called democratic racial set their
capitalism for fifteen percent of people
or thirty percent of people rather than
0.1% is not justice or democracy we can
take heart in remembering that
authoritarian neoliberalism is weak in
part because it doesn't exist like it
claims to exist it enforces appearances
of transact ability that are not real in
the same sense the diversity of social
production are real and alternate modes
of collectivities strengthen and
continue to circulate resistance to old
and new neoliberalism cz's everywhere
and we are seen it on the streets of
Hong Kong Lebanon Chile Haiti Catalonia
Iraq and Palestine were demands for a
good life and
post sectarian politics beyond the
formulas and strangled capacities of
neoliberal states are really being
called for loudly across the u.s.
powerful collectives of solidarities are
developing under so many names black
lives matter
communities not cages never again is now
and I am certain that chundan ready when
he gives his talk in a few weeks
we'll be talking about how in the u.s.
the most vital social movement groups
working on race into Jannetty migrants
and poverty are being led by the very
activists and predominantly queer women
of color who have longed works against
administrative violence administrative
controls in public assistance in
immigration in Corrections I hope that
by identifying how administrative power
makes the violence required for racial
colonial capital accumulation appear
ordinary we can see resistance beyond
the usual elitism of our politics of
political knowledge because it's not I
think in the end programmatic politics
that defeats administrated discretion
and impunity and abstraction and
reduction but interdependence grounded
relationality deep context and
attunement to materialize in social
process by living not as an individual
unit in the recursive teleology of
administrative time but collectively in
the open future anterior Eddy of
everyday revolutionary time thank you
guys for your patience thank you
okay thank you thank you so new work
love any thoughts and feelings I also
really like doing Q&A as discussions
right so feel free to talk to each other
if you hear somebody talking about
something you're interested in applying
it to your work anything anything like
that would be great but I would love
love to hear some thoughts and I would
love to drink a little water too so
please take your time
thank you thank you guys thank you for
coming on Halloween I know I know I feel
really grateful thank you thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know my great or utilization of
migrant labor yeah sorry fine but what I
was reflecting on is you were pointing
to something more deeply horrifying
we're not more additionally horrifying
and yeah you're you switched from
speaking of an administrative power mmm
the administrative state I know I did
that yeah it's an example a little much
about what we're in right now and so I
was just wondering if we could speak
about that transition yeah and the ways
in which a minute a sense what you're
describing under Trump
is the did you put it
both the dismantling and the seizing of
different agencies in order to I know I
know I mean I guess I mean one ass
example is it like when you think about
administrative power in general and then
we need to think about in the state but
I mean we also have to think about how
all of the administrative apparatus is
that existed even before they were like
being hollowed out are still problematic
right like meritocracy and
professionalism you know I mean with the
things that we bemoan the end of and we
really genuinely Bend among the end of
them are also barriers their regulators
their modes of again seeing who's
legitimate and who's illegitimate right
there they're they also kind of insulate
the state from having to deal with the
economic violence it produces right in
various ways so so there's like the
Trump version of it there's the thinking
about the problem of administrative
apparatus is already you guys all know
the critique of the New Deal state right
but I guess then I want to think like we
need to just like the the whole way that
democratic process has been taken for
allowing capless violence to kind of
continue right administrative process to
let it be unknown until let it be made
ordinary I wanted to not be made
ordinary and I want that to be
recognized right like it's not law
happening neutrally right it's not
professionals deciding who gets student
financial aid money and who doesn't
right I mean there is that but that's
reproducing class mobility for some and
possibilities of entrance into class
mobility for others and that's not you
know taking social process together and
deciding where we want to take our
ability to make things happen right so
there's something about wanting to I
guess this is a nihilistic desire is it
a creative designer right but it's
something about say
in this ordinary making doing the
unknowing thing because it's easy to do
it's how the structures are set up
rather than like okay let's think about
how we're all here now and we're in the
city and we're in this place and we're
interdependent on each other and we're
independent with the earth and you know
my ability to breathe is dependent and
to like survive is dependent on you guys
in various ways and the context it goes
so much deeper right that you can't you
can't stop it where the state stops it
as like that was a public policy
decision out of the question right we
need really new context rich complex
personality modes of understanding
ourselves as collective right that take
the injustice of the past that are
whitewashed three things like inherit
and inherited wealth etc and just like
radically make them available for
relating to each other through them in
ways that are fair and how does that
happen I don't know right I mean I do
think that like one of the things that's
scary for me is that I do think the
administrative state is going I think
that it's becoming this executive
wielding deal-making thing but I don't
think going back to it would be like I
like good or possible right in some ways
and it's like it's like we can't be
separated from what's going on in
Lebanon now or Palestine because the
elites aren't separated you know what I
mean they're using the same technologies
of control and policing and there has to
be way a feeling interdependent people
power beyond nation-state boundaries you
know what I mean I mean it's like very
you topic and nihilistic together but I
also think that it's kind of happening
right it's like people are reflecting
and like like the Sackler is you know
like it used to be when I was growing up
in the university right it was like the
fact that you could like know who your
board members were and try to kick them
out and criticize them the idea that
they could do things with impunity
because they were the ones who knew and
they had all the facts but I think
that's over I think the day of non-trans
are transparent boards is like dying and
I think that's a really that's a really
good thing right for individual
institutions right like we want to know
who's on our board we want to you know
know what they're doing we want to be
involved in that so that's my response
and capital at this moment seems more
contradictory and man I think for
example about like tariffs mental
regulation when actually are splits and
there's no singular sense yeah what its
relationship yeah to reproduce the
conditions of accumulation and the
second part is I'm thinking about these
kind of low-level justice reform mmm-hmm
right yeah it's actually about yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that isn't really good so
I guess good thing going on you know and
then nineties like during wet
stop-and-frisk
that seems to be
right like 1 2 1 yeah yeah I mean I do
think it's more chaotic I think I did a
bad job of trying to say what I want to
say which is because I don't think it's
connected to like one formation of you
know sedimented out is the momentarily
dominant capsulation I think that we're
in a period now where accumulation
happens pass opportunistically you need
the police to do this at one time and
that at another time right so I think
that there's there's something about
taking police power and spreading it
everywhere right so that you know like
one day you might need this you know
river head police and the people who are
like like pacify the people are trying
to stop it from being developed right
another time you might need this
downtown area cleared out I mean I think
what I miss talking about is sort of how
policing is responsive to resistance
right and how its tracking that around
but I I'm trying to get it something
about the need to at least do to
adjudicate on the ground conditions for
a really fast
opportunistic deal making kind of
capitalism right that's like now this
this part is open now this part is
closed now we need to send the police to
California to make emissions you know to
like police cars to make sure they give
out more emissions you know what I mean
like our you know or like you're a
border patrol guard this moment now
you're private corporate poor policing
the poor right of course that's a really
profound thing but there's there's
something about the speed
interoperability lack of accountability
the need for coercive apparatuses to be
that net right that I think I need to
you know I'm still doing your writing I
need to find better examples and I need
to write like give some more concrete
examples of these fusions right you guys
all know about fusion centers right that
bring together there's they're really
bad right they don't actually predict
any kind of crime and stop crime usually
but they send a lot of information to a
lot of places right so they send the FBI
and the military and the local police
and then like hospital records right all
can be put in the central part and then
activists can be picked out from it like
that like that sort of thing and and
like the ACLU is constantly
saying this is the problem with fusion
centers right they bring military into
policing they are unaccountable right
they have this administrative complexity
that makes them unaccountable they
gather tons of information so they're
violating civil rights but they had to
sign a waiver saying they wouldn't
violate anybody still arrive so there
you go it's all good anyway there's a
lot of that like certifying that amuse
another form of administrative violence
right like we sign the waiver you know
nothing could happen but that that's
exactly what makes them powerful it's
just that that kind of expansion like
that I'm trying to catch a hold of with
interoperability but I'm not I'm not
there yet and I do think that it's hard
because it's a Fastpass opportunistic
making crisis managing kind of time
right with this extractive logistical of
financial eyes this abandon it now
extract from it you know what I mean so
I need I need better examples
point well-taken yes yes I know right
that'll be in the next part right
because I do think that is really true
right because I and other times I've
tried to talk about this with the help
of a colleague named Lisa Quecha as a
kind of power that is like glass right
that it kind of believes in its own
inevitable it'll you know invisibility
inevitability and it's sort of like like
glass and that you don't see it like it
tries to be a kind of power that you
don't see you just kind of see through
you don't notice but in fact it's
actually really vulnerable to shattering
right because it never works like it
says it's gonna work right these are the
lives right the lives of how things are
supposed to work and like human to
anything that has to go through human
beings is much more variable is you know
like it's always resisted all the time
you can't you know it's it's not it's
not it's not how human beings live their
lives in relation to each other right
there isn't an omniscient no no there
isn't I mean anyone who's gone to
Palestine there was the idea that
they're gonna stop everybody from
getting you know getting in yeah it's
not it's not a mission at all right
there's a lot of waste and no
omniscience and yet it's not I mean I
guess then the likes but it's it's it's
still not something that normal politics
you know what I mean is getting a hold
on
right so it's more like on the streets
resistance social movement resistance
living lies resistance and I guess it's
just another version of like you know
something that it's controlling kind of
normal politics the way that we need to
kind of step over and go around right in
terms of like making life together yeah
everybody yeah I mean it does feel that
I would describe do you guys feel that
do it is what I was described I think
it's true do you think it's true do you
think it's overstated or do you feel
like you know there's something there's
some other categorical way we need to
think about it yes
maybe maybe first I really love this
talk and I think it's you know just
amazing and I really want to kind of
build on what Danny and Lisa were asking
you um which is that this is a talk
that's really looking at at capital's
perspective of power yes and and we
might reorient it as well from from
those who are affected by it powers
relationship - that's the light glass
part so those who are affected man can
actually see the lie all the time right
that's like the cydia Hartman wayward
lives beautiful experiment and and so
the other part yes yes but you yes but
and this is and this is just to build on
this question of how it breaks normal
politics and maybe have your library
on it which is you know I wonder if if
we take the example of Ferguson or Eric
Gardner and the informal economy where
survival economies or subsist various
forms of you know multi job economies
produce the means of living then what
we're talking about is a particular way
in which poverty capital is being
created you know sort of an onion rose
notion and the degree to which poverty
capital is administrated and it would be
the difference between in the Oakland
account you know something like the poor
who might still become as a reserve army
of labor for the working class
and and the brat and and I came up with
the name was for the other side of the
parabola the rabble you know and and and
that division of course is a racial
division in our in our world and and so
when you when administrative power is
operationalizing you know the kind of
poverty capital making out of the breath
out of the rabble I think that that's
one example where we have what you were
talking about in the beginning of your
talk which is it's a part of its
effectivity is that people don't have
the language to describe its violation
in the terms of liberal political idioms
and in the public sphere so so I think
of all the people you know who are
organizing in Ferguson who would make
analogies to slavery and they say that
this was a modern-day slavery and people
said oh you know you're really
misunderstanding what's going on here
and so forth but what they were
capturing was that from their
perspective capital making is violence
making oh there is no idiom for that in
political life oh there's only you know
legal and illegal you know
legitimate illegitimate so on and so I
really appreciate your sense that part
of what's what is effective about this
is that it creates modes of enactment
for which the resistance has its
genealogy is in the long black radical
tradition or genealogy is in thee is in
precisely the subaltern movements that
have been foreclosed from the national
public sphere do you know yeah that's
very helpful why the language doesn't
get there
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
like so like he's calling you said let's
make a deal twice in that very short
letter and I was like yes I mean I think
that there were more elites who agreed
with what was going on right there's a
wider political ruling class right like
hunter Biden right what he did was you
know I kind of like he was sitting on a
board because his father was vice
president and it was legal right but uh
but there was a whole group of political
did I sorry okay like you know like the
political class accepted that right the
way that lobbying worked in that way
right that that was like accepted
because a lot of people got to be part
of it right and now it does seem like
this more narrow like fight within the
ruling class right and we get an
exposure something that was basically
happening all along but it's happening
now in a more authoritarian direct you
know sort of like plutocratic way yeah
yeah I think it is a time of exposure
right a lot of things does what do you
think about that does that like give you
hope or do you want like you know what I
mean like just any thoughts you have on
it
yes what do ya not I have a necessary I
don't think okay that better or worse it
avoids going on but I think it's
interesting yeah there is now shift to
like I mean the power relationships
between us very interesting some cover
[Music]
really good question anybody else want
to respond to that any thoughts about
that really good thoughts yeah
[Music]
kind of implicit critique of bureaucracy
by the bureaucracies then we even go
beyond that mortis the administrator as
the deal maker and this sort of seems
that such on your point you mentioned
fascism once twice fascism in a sense of
yeah yeah especially thinking of the new
right simultaneously arising in terms of
new left
hmm I'm wondering what thinking in terms
of what are the yeah yeah what does that
look like and the reason why I also
mention that you left is I don't
listening to your talk I think there's
almost no coincidence that Foucault and
the Blues are actually speaking in terms
of fascism
what are the politics that come out of
this I mean it's interesting right
because I heard just a little bit at the
end and I know I didn't do it sense
actually and I need a lot more time to
do it satisfactory but it is a politics
that makes us leave our usually like it
might not be recognized as a politics
anymore right so the words I tried to
talk about words like interdependence
and grandeur relationality which is
coming out of indigenous studies which
is the idea that we do solidarity to
each other by developing kind of
obligations land base a sense of land a
gentle and like how do we share this
land in a way that's good for all of us
right so it's coming out of not liberal
frameworks anymore so it doesn't sound
political in the same way anymore it's
coming out like another phrase that just
comes to my mind these things feel real
right when you're in the moment of like
doing direct action when you're in the
moment of doing guest-host relationships
with people you're supposed to be
separated from right like a Jew in
Palestine right in the West Bank or
something and they feel like guest-host
relationships they feel like kinship
they feel like building the strong
connections and networks so that the
abstractions and partitions don't divide
us any more right so that we know each
other's full context and we you know
like like laugh at the attempt to
administrate us as enemies to each other
you know what I mean so it's a very
weird people based kind of politics it's
a very like two-speed kind of politics
like a direct action kind of politics
but also like a speed of like learning
reading knowing more than we can know
knowing more than the critique right and
that's always gonna be hard like knowing
not just what's wrong but knowing the
other thing that's going on right and so
it's hard to stand in the classroom and
talk about that other thing right I can
talk about my communities of learning
from indigenous communities in Wisconsin
right and how I learned that like even
though they were supposed to be
terminated they were nothing like
terminated you know what I mean and that
even though their forests are supposed
to be their source of income they're
much more than that you know what I mean
or other communities that you know are
my communities
learning but to bring this in to bring
it in here as that politics feels like I
can just gesture towards it but it feels
like it's like you got to be you got to
be in it together which is not it's not
programmatic in any way right it's like
developing habits of interdependence II
seeing the lie not participating in the
unknowing fighting for complex
personhood you know I mean it's about
empowerment of not empowered communities
I mean it's about like it's like a big
thing is that you know what I mean it's
you know is it DSA I can't say that I
can't give you a presidential candidate
[Laughter]
[Music]
do ya yeah did you ever
[Music]
totally I have it but it sounds great I
mean it sounds like a very rich a rich
vein to think about yeah there's a book
about to come out called digitized and
punished by Brian Jordan Jefferson that
gives the full history of criminal
justice technologies like from the 50s
to now and the kinds of operability is
that they make possible but also how
they can be fought right like good
fighting databases and something people
are doing all the time right and that's
that seems really necessary and exciting
right so yeah I wanna hear more work on
that and send it to me yeah
[Laughter]
mm-hmm I know right I knew you're gonna
say that yeah yeah totally yeah I
completely agree
it is colonialism I mean it is
capitalism is always colonialism right
liberalism comes out of colonialism
absolutely so you know it is of course
nothing new Under Sun I think the thing
that is new is the attempt to really
kill these the normal way the
administrative agencies have functioned
right to like really make sure there's
nothing in the way of like oil gas
steelmaking right and that it's enforced
in certain ways but the general thing
right capitalism does work you're
deal-making get Louisiana Purchase we've
got like columbic coloniality like
colonialism it is colonialism right like
and that's interesting to me right which
is like what like like we are like the
colonialism was never not in the
nation-state
right at any time how do we talk about
like the colonialism that was the high
period of the nation-state in the West
right like we often talk about them as
Imperial States but it feels like it was
always more than that too that they were
also always colonial right and I feel
like tracing those modes right it's
really it's really like the trismus
modes through jurisdiction making right
thinking especially inside the colonial
societies like maybe seeing how that
works inside the clinic sighs it's
something that can tell us more about
how it worked more generally I think
it's something that I think some folks
are doing an indigenous legal stuff and
that I think I think we we need to do a
lot more because you're right it's
colonialism it is indeed
yeah yeah that resistance yeah yeah yeah
yeah security administrator - yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yes exciting parts of that destruction
happening you know what I mean and it is
happening at different levels right of
governance
like I mean states are where state
houses is where there was the resistance
at first and also like the cunning
capture of using rules to you know push
through different gerrymandered
districts or different kinds of powers
that legislators that have a majority
majority used to now keep themselves
right just really not pretending that
democracy was in the rules and there's
any difference between them just using
the power of rules but always been
hitting on more resistance right like
teacher the wildcat strikes of teachers
i mean another way to talk about this
would be that like all of this
incredible not just resistance but new
relationships and new ways with people
living together right is happening all
at the same time you know so yeah like
it's it that they're the the resistance
part is very exciting and maybe one can
and should start there so we don't get
like feel depressed
I'm kind of like I've been told that you
know I'm better at the recitation of
oppression than I am at the rehearsal
for freedom pirate but I get there I get
there eventually
it's but my brain downstairs I kind of
wish it did okay we stopped bit about
how you kind of took us through and so
so the the kind of the element of the
storytelling have that can affix to the
physical storytelling about the meaning
read the real being always moral and
always dividing us into groups so I was
thinking if we can bring that back and
then okay so I can see two genres about
the way administrative power talks about
itself which tries very deliberately to
bore us to death
yeah cos no each we are very bored
sounding really long so destroying tight
with the epic story
authentic story of a new kind of
antihero in chunk so there are in this
hyper spectral Specter Eliza is
disrespectful of trauma
so on the one hand the really dry form
and the really dry jarrah of the
ministry force together with this really
enthralling one had like a day
[Music]
interesting interesting yeah yeah yeah
interesting genre yeah mix yeah
effective writers good that's very
helpful now I want to keep thinking
about that yeah yeah I don't think I
have an immediate response other than
that sounds right and yeah yeah do you
have thoughts beyond that I just want
yeah yeah yeah I mean I guess that's
sort of the end is like like not being
lulled by the non-story and seeing it as
a lie you know what I mean something
like that would be yeah yeah the power
of the fairy tale yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely well thank you God I mean
honestly thank you this is brand-new off
the brain so you've given me lots to
think about
and as I reworked this over the next
months it'll this is really will be
helpful so I'm really grateful to each
and every one of you for
[Music]